gary meant so much to all of las vegas
and for those of us at 8 news now his
impact immeasurable sasha loftis takes a
look back at the ways he made our
newsroom what it is today
we are back with more of our coverage
his voice could soothe the saddest of
days and his stories shaped our city for
decades the las vegas strip was almost
deserted but for so many here at 8 news
now gary waddell was light laughter and
a symbol of what tv news truly means it
was like he was woven into
the fabric of las vegas his time here in
our newsroom will always be remembered
as he brought his talent sound logic and
unwavering friendship i was so lucky to
have him as a friend i was so lucky to
have him as a colleague it's been nearly
10 years since gary retired and we still
have this box here today 30 years worth
of newspaper clips and photos just a
true testament to the history he
witnessed and the impact he'll have for
so much time to come we showed you the
top 19 stories his former co-anchor and
long time friend paula francis says gary
also spent so much time helping others
and sharing his unparalleled experience
he was so in tune to
current events
to news to history and he really wanted
to impart that to young people gary
always said
find the smartest people you can and
hire them and teach them tv so while
those who knew him are still full of
sorrow
they can also take comfort in the
countless ways he changed the world
one newscast at a time my name is gary
waddell in las vegas
[Music]
sasha loftis 8 news now